I've been thinking about it for a long time, but Kuzuhara's clothes Ah, I'll buy that
b Strange ah ah ah
Well, it doesn't matter who the
stitcher is.
I don't have anything in particular. There are
times when
you can't help but come here. It's short-sighted to think that Yukimura is the same because you
're like that.  Ah
, I'm your ally
I don't feel like black or white
Living is empty and painful and painful I
want to
lean on someone That's what it feels like to miss someone It's
like I don't care about myself It's
just a little  Chased by the warmth of
wish I want to
forget everything else I can forget everything I want to forget that's
why I'm a
hero